hola a todos aquí me gustaría hablar de
las funciones armónicas muy bien
entonces en este vídeo vamos a hablar de
las funciones armónicas que en realidad
son un tipo muy especial de funciones de
varias variables y se definen en
términos del la plaza no verdad entonces
recordemos que nosotros ya hemos
definido en los vídeos anteriores en la
plastia no de una función que puede
depender de varias variables en este
vídeo vamos a pensar en una función de
dos variables y esto lo definimos como
la divergencia del gradiente de nuestra
función f y por supuesto esto lo
evaluamos en el punto que nos interese
verdad entonces esto ya hemos discutido
que digamos que extiende la la idea de
la segunda derivada verdad entonces las
funciones armónicas se definen en
términos de la plastia no y vamos a
decir que una función es armónica si su
la plastia no es cero en todos los
puntos de nuestro espacio de entrada si
algunas personas para enfatizar que
se da en todos los puntos xy digamos en
el espacio de entradas le ponen una
tercera línea esto enfatiza que se debe
cumplir en todo x es decir que la plaza
no es idénticamente 0 entonces en
realidad esto no representa una ecuación
sino afirma algo de nuestra función f
que estamos considerando y para pensar
digamos un poquito en la intuición de lo
que son las funciones armónicas pensemos
en las funciones escalares es decir que
toman una variable de entrada y una
varias y tendremos una sola salida
verdad entonces pensemos en el caso en
una función escalar es decir
consideramos la segunda derivada de
nuestra función y que esto sea cero en
todos los puntos de digamos de entrada
verdad entonces si nosotros pensamos en
esto a la hora de integrar esta función
es decir pensamos en aquellas funciones
cuya
derivada verdad es 0 verdad y eso
querría decir que son las funciones
constantes entonces el hecho de que la
segunda derivada sea 0 siempre significa
que la primera derivada es constante en
todos lados y nuevamente si integramos
tendremos que nuestra función
f x sería igual a c por x más cualquier
otra constante entonces típicamente esto
se ve como una función lineal verdad es
decir la gráfica de nuestra función es
esencialmente una línea recta entonces
esto esto tiene mucho sentido verdad si
por ejemplo le damos una interpretación
a la segunda derivada verdad porque por
ejemplo si tuviéramos otro caso en donde
no nuestra función no fuera una línea
sino que se viera no sé quizás más o
menos algo así verdad entonces cuando
tenemos este caso aquí tenemos una parte
en donde es como cóncava hacía bajo
verdad y esto ocurre siempre que la
segunda derivada de f
negativa en cambio en esta parte donde
tenemos concavidad hacia arriba
tendremos que la segunda derivada de
nuestra función es positiva verdad para
tener la concavidad hacia arriba en
cambio si la segunda derivada es siempre
cero entonces no puede curvarse verdad
no podemos tener concavidad hacia abajo
ni concavidad hacia arriba así que la
única forma que tenemos es una línea
recta verdad no puede curvarse ahora
bien si usamos la idea de una función de
varias variables entonces aquí es en
donde se puede poner mucho más
interesante que estas funciones lineales
aquí tengo una gráfica verdad que es la
gráfica de una función armónica y en
realidad es la gráfica de la siguiente
función tenemos la función f x y lo voy
a hacer mejor con verde
con verde entonces tenemos la función f
de x
y esta es la función e elevado a la x
que multiplica al seno de iu muy bien
entonces esta es la función que tenemos
aquí graficada y al fijarnos en la
gráfica de aquí espero que esto tenga
mucho más sentido de porque esto es más
o menos algo como ea la x por seno de
verdad entonces a medida que nos movemos
en la dirección de x verdad si nos
movemos en esta dirección
esencialmente tenemos esta forma
exponencial que vemos aquí verdad
entonces lo único que ocurre es que esto
está haciendo x otra cosa que es una
función de ye verdad entonces si
mantenemos allí constante en realidad
esto se ve como una constante verdad
entonces notemos que si esa constante
fuera negativa verdad si el seno del en
algún punto resulta ser negativo
entonces toda nuestra función
exponencial en realidad se va hacia
abajo verdad entonces es cómo era la
equis verdad pero al revés y verdad así
que si imaginamos que ahora nos mueve
en la dirección de verdad en vez de la
dirección x si nos movemos a lo largo de
la dirección de verdad vemos que tenemos
esta forma si no se nos oirá la verdad
entonces esto tiene sentido porque
tenemos el seno de jeff y depende la
digamos la amplitud depende de quién sea
ea la equis verdad la amplitud de esta
onda va a depender de la equis y será
muy alta en puntos en donde ella la
equis sea muy grande verdad pero será
muy pequeña cuando ella la equis sea muy
muy pequeño así que de hecho es muy
difícil de notar lo que se está
ocurriendo por aquí verdad así que esta
es la gráfica que estamos mirando y yo
afirmo que esta función es armónica
verdad es decir que ésta es una función
cuyo la plastia no es igual a cero
verdad entonces recordemos cómo es que
podemos calcular esto nosotros sabemos
que en la plastia no verdad de una
función en la plaza no de una función en
cualquier punto se puede calcular bueno
por supuesto como la divergencia del
gradiente pero tenemos otro método para
calcular lo que es sumar la segunda
derivadas parciales de nuestra función
entonces sumamos la segunda derivada
parcial de f con respecto de x ambas
veces y la segunda derivada de f con
respecto de ambas veces y si tuviéramos
más variables pues entonces sumaríamos
más segundas derivadas parciales y yo
afirmo entonces que esto es igual a cero
y por supuesto esto se puede quedar como
un ejercicio para ti verdad es muy fácil
y se sirve que te familiarizas con el
cálculo de la plastia no y lo
interesante aquí es ver cómo se
interpreta este hecho verdad el hecho de
que la plastia no se anule en todos
lados entonces otra forma de interpretar
a la segunda derivada es de esta forma
verdad si por ejemplo nos fijamos en
esta parte de aquí de nuestra función
esta parte digamos está curvando de esta
forma es cóncava hacia abajo entonces
por ejemplo pensemos en este punto
máximo de por aquí entonces este punto
máximo de por aquí en realidad es porque
todos digamos en puntos vecinos de
nuestra función
tendremos que el valor bajo la función
menor a este máximo verdad justamente
por eso es por eso es máximo pero
también una forma de pensar a la segunda
derivada es de la siguiente forma
tenemos que la segunda derivada en
nuestro punto x0 que pensamos por
ejemplo que es el máximo esto resulta
ser negativo verdad entonces qué es lo
que ocurriría digamos si estamos de este
lado bueno de este lado ocurre
exactamente lo contrario en lugar de
tener una segunda derivada negativa
vamos a tener una segunda derivada
positiva verdad en este caso sería una
segunda derivada positiva entonces
imaginamos otra situación en donde
tengamos también nuestros ejes verdad y
ahora tenemos una función que más o
menos se ve así es decir que no tengamos
mínimos y máximos si tenemos un punto
digamos x0 en este caso tendremos un
punto x0 verdad y éste es digamos el
valor de su función entonces podemos
tomar un punto a la izquierda y un punto
a la derecha que se encuentra en más o
menos a la misma distancia de x
verdad entonces nos fijamos en sus
valores aquí está el valor de este punto
y acá estaría el valor de este otro
punto verdad entonces en este caso la
segunda derivada de la función evaluada
en el punto x0 es positiva verdad
justamente por esta idea de concavidad
hacia arriba sin embargo podemos ver que
del lado derecho
esta función crece muchísimo lo cual nos
dice que en promedio la función tiende a
ser mayor en sus vecinos que le digamos
tiende a ser mayor en los vecinos de x0
en promedio verdad y la razón por la
cual digo esto es porque la idea de la
plastia no y en el mundo de las
funciones de varias variables eso es
mejor tratar de entenderlas
de esta forma así que si nos fijamos en
esta función y lo vemos desde arriba
como si fuéramos volando verdad tenemos
nuestro plano xy con el eje x el eje y y
nos fijamos en cualquier punto de
entrada específico entonces para
entender a la plastia no pensemos
primero en círculos alrededor de este
punto
entonces pensamos en todos los vecinos
que se encuentran sobre este círculo
perfecto es decir aquellos que están a
una distancia específica del punto de
interés verdad así que la pregunta que
vamos a responder con el la plastia no
es bueno si tenemos nuestros vecinos en
promedio van a tomar valores mayores o
menores que nuestro punto original y de
hecho así fue como hicimos la
introducción de la plaza no en el vídeo
original en donde estábamos dando cierta
intuición para este operador verdad nos
preguntamos alrededor de nuestros puntos
de entrada que ocurre resultan tomar
valores mayores o menores en promedio
verdad y si nos fijamos en un punto en
donde la plaza no de la función tiene un
valor positivo digamos en este punto eso
significa que todos los vecinos tienden
a ser en promedio mayores que nuestro
punto verdad bajo la función así que si
nos fijamos en el punto en donde la
plaza no de la función es
más chico que 0 entonces todos los
vecinos en promedio tienden a tener
menores valores bajo la función verdad
es por eso que en este caso nuestro
punto tiende a parecerse más a un máximo
local verdad si por ejemplo en la playa
no fuera mayor que serán un punto
entonces en realidad se vería un poquito
más parecido a un mínimo porque todos
los vecinos tendrían un valor mayor que
lo que es en el punto original pero las
funciones armónicas son muy especiales
porque nos está diciendo que el valor de
la función en sí mismo digamos el valor
de la plaza no de la función en todo
punto es igual a cero es decir en
promedio verdad en cualquier punto
posible
los vecinos van a tomar en promedio el
mismo valor que este punto de aquí es
decir la altura de la gráfica por arriba
de estos vecinos será en promedio el
mismo así que si nos fijamos por ejemplo
en la gráfica esto es lo que significa
verdad si nos fijamos en un punto de
entrada sabemos que la salida de este
punto verdad se va a parecer más o menos
a todos los demás alrededor es decir a
este círculo de vecinos
si los proyectamos sobre la gráfica esto
significa que la altura de todos estos
puntos en el círculo en promedio son los
mismos verdad no importa donde nos
fijemos y nuevamente te invito a que te
fijes en esta función y realmente
calcule ese la plaza no para convencerte
de que es cero en todos lados pero lo
que es interesante es que al fijarnos en
la x por el seno de verdad el valor
promedio de este círculo en estos puntos
verdad siempre va a ser igual al valor
del punto central esto no es algo que
sea tan fácil de ver a partir de la
fórmula pero en realidad no es un
cálculo tan complicado como para que
podamos hacer esta conclusión verdad que
es muy muy muy interesante y esto en
realidad aparece siempre en la física
así que por ejemplo si estamos
calentando algo y queremos describir
cómo es que el calor digamos en un punto
dado de un cuarto está relacionado con
el valor promedio del calor de sus
puntos vecinos verdad en realidad
podríamos pensar en muchísimas otras
circunstancias verdad donde tengamos un
punto en el espacio físico y qué
pensar en algo acerca de ese punto no sé
quizás la tasa a la cual cierta
propiedad cambia o cómo se cómo
podríamos corresponder lo con el valor
promedio de sus puntos alrededor de él
verdad así que siempre que estemos
relacionando vecinos con nuestro punto
original en la plastia no va a aparecer
y las funciones armónicas tienen esta
tendencia a corresponder con cierta
noción de estabilidad verdad pero ya no
vamos a hablar mucho más en detalle de
todo esto en realidad esto empieza a
introducirse en el tema de las
ecuaciones diferenciales parciales pero
al menos en el contexto del cálculo de
varias variables quería darte un indicio
un poquito de intuición de cómo en
interpretar este operador verdad y
tratar de interpretar esto en términos
físicos y geométricos bueno con esto
terminamos y nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo